i'm going to regret this when my phone
dies later but
get off of it no i like being live
all right guys
um
so tonight
going
[Music]
reporting live on pearls
we have anu
we have chloe
this side
we have
corrine
and ashlyn
and gabby
got a little pringle actually over here
who's live yeah you're watching hello
everyone
hello it's girl's friend everyone
this is
eileen shame
um
your girl just got a job she's also in
university for her master's but if you
would like to donate to support her
i would very much appreciate it
hanzo or venmo venmo
e-i-l-e-n-s-h-i-32 also my instagram
handle
but you know let's stop
oh here you go pearl what's going on the
platform
this is probably my birthday oh okay
hey guys
this is the biscuit train to eat they
like you
they like you
there's 12 people
guys send a donation for the sound board
please
send money somebody we're trying to
raise money
what are you that's what i do in my
lives how do you think i've raised the
money before
me and g are the only
sober ones here but you wouldn't know it
because we're such big balls of fun wait
what i said we're the only sober ones
here well you wouldn't know it because
you're such big balls
um
she said she wouldn't date a guy that
works at a gas station
on that live
what you said on my other live i was
like
what are you doing
i don't understand what people say my
business i'm like what is my business
thank you for the five dollar super chat
does that give you money yeah five bucks
three minutes i told you
it's because i'm on the chat i'm just
kidding look at it thank you guys i
appreciate you so much
i appreciate it i that's i'm at 200 so i
want to get four more mics and another
sound board
i'm at 250 now out of the
a thousand dollars i need to raise for
the next one so so if you're feeling
kind of generous
[Music]
this is in the uk yeah but we're not
with any british girls like all
americans yeah
[Music]
hold on
it's like this artist i forget his name
guys